[Music]
on this wednesday night the promise of
more covet 19 rapid tests
and before christmas it was like the
hunger games trying to get a rapid test
what the federal government says it will
deliver to combat long lines and short
supplies partying like there's no
pandemic
the federal investigation into these sun
wing passengers and how will they get
home
kazakhstan's state of
emergency what's behind the violent
protests and why the world is watching
closely
and pontificating on parenthood there's
a small irony about a man who's never
had children telling people about having
children the pope takes aim at people
who choose to have pets
instead of children
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are midway into the first week of
january 2022 and canadians are again
being told to be patient almost two
years since the pandemic began covet
case counts have reached record levels
prime minister justin trudeau says it is
understandable people are frustrated
especially at seeing surgeries postponed
and having to endure more public health
restrictions he appealed to the
unvaccinated to get their first shot
they'd much rather be giving you an
injection a vaccine
then intubating you in an icu
many canadians aren't even able to get
tested for covid right now the prime
minister is promising 140 million rapid
tests will be delivered to the provinces
and territories by the end of the month
our coverage tonight begins with abigail
beeman
two hours two hours yeah hoping that
being here two hours in advance will
give us that opportunity a cold weight
for rapid tests in toronto
and the supply ran dry in 20 minutes
i've been lined up here in the cold for
hours
i'm lining up actually for people who
can't line up they're seniors they've
got cancer
this is terrible ottawa now promising
140 million more rapid tests will arrive
this month one rapid test per week per
person in canada for in january the
prime minister acknowledged people are
frustrated and tired launching his first
news conference of 2022 with lines you
might remember from 2021 and 2020. we
have to hunker down
we have to pull together and it gets
better
in a few months we're looking at a
better spring as long as we all keep
doing our part january 2022 is not march
2020.
we have made significant progress of
course there are now vaccines and for
some rapid tests but with rollout up to
the provinces it's a patchwork people in
bc may envy those long toronto lines
since the general public can't yet
easily access any what we've seen now
in the the last few months
is the creation of i'll call it an
underground economy
for rapid tests
the co-chair of canada's testing
advisory panel says 140 million more
tests are a good start but she'd like to
see clarity and consistency across the
board families in provinces that have
access to them
are selling them to
people in other provinces or sending
them to family members in other
provinces we've heard about hoarding
we've heard about
inequitable access to these tests before
christmas it was like the hunger games
trying to get a rapid test the
conservative leader said he's frustrated
accusing the prime minister of
normalizing lockdowns and restrictions
as the main tool to fight covet the
federal advisory panel called for the
equitable use of rapid tests for
screening a full year ago january 2021.
donna
beeman in ottawa thanks well
hospitalizations are beginning to rise
in ontario the system is under pressure
that province leads the country with
more than 2 000 people in the hospital
with covid19
791 patients were admitted yesterday
alone and staffing levels are beginning
to plummet as front line workers test
positive a hospital in fort erie ontario
is temporarily shutting down because of
a staffing shortage the health authority
says it's redeploying highly trained
nurses and doctors to other emergency
departments in the niagara region the
new province-wide covet-19 restrictions
come into effect today and are aimed at
easing the burden on hospitals but as
mike delay reports struggling businesses
are being hit and many are again
desperate for help
it's lonely today at tom vasilowski's
bar there's no raising a pint here or
anywhere for that matter indeed the only
thing he's raising are the chairs as
government restrictions mandating the
closure of indoor dining come into
effect i don't know how many more times
we can do this i mean
we might have to eventually close down
for a while and hopefully not lose our
staff and that's my biggest worry these
guys have been with me for 25 to 30
years
so
they rely on me and i rely on them
tom like so many other small business
owners had hoped they were in the clear
the vaccine passport system was supposed
to allow them to keep the doors open
instead they're stuck in a financial
groundhog day for the fourth time we've
had to lay off staff
you know
people are losing their jobs once again
the canadian federation of independent
business predicted at the beginning of
september that one in six owners
wouldn't make it through the pandemic a
figure that will certainly worsen now
with another round of lockdowns though i
suspect many will be making the decision
to throw in the towel they just don't
see a pathway back to profitability
and they're they're struggling they're
drowning with the debt that they've
taken on the latest public health
measures which also includes capacity
limits for retail and closures for
concert venues and cinemas will last
through january 26th an expanded rebate
system announced by the ontario
government was widely panned by business
owners leading to a second announcement
that a grant program is in the works i'm
in a situation where i can somewhat
sustain but it is getting to a point
where it's like
enough is enough i i'm frustrated i'm
angry and i'm disappointed i'm concerned
i don't usually lose sleep but i'm
wondering how i'm going to pay my staff
business owners say they'd like to
believe the government that this
lockdown will be short but they've heard
that before
mike girlie global news toronto
winnipeg's police chief is declaring a
rare state of emergency for the force
itself staff levels are taking a big hit
from covet 19. there are at least 90
active cases among members now and 170
other staff are off work for coveted
related reasons the department is
redeploying 80 people from other units
to ensure that general patrols in the
city continue
a group of quebec social media
influencers is stuck in mexico and
there's not a lot of sympathy for them
they chartered a sun wing flight to take
them to cancun to celebrate new year's
eve images were posted online showing
them breaking just about every rule in
the book and their return flight has now
been cancelled as mike armstrong
explains no other airline wants to bring
them home
they got the party they were after but
the after party has been a problem it
was sold as a six night all-inclusive
trip to cancun the advertising included
the promise of a private plane with dj
organizers chartered a flight with the
airline sun wing and it turned into
basically a free-for-all no masks
drinking out of bottles vaping it got so
rowdy there were reports the flight
attendants had to hide in the back of
the plane
these three passengers posted an apology
on instagram wednesday saying they
didn't expect the flight to degenerate
the way it did that it was unacceptable
and that they weren't involved
now the group did make it to cancun but
when videos started hitting social media
they hit the news and sunwing canceled
the group's return flight scheduled for
thursday global news has obtained an
internal email the company sent to
employees it says it notified transport
canada of the group's unruly behavior
well they weren't the only ones the
federal transport minister called for an
investigation i'm extremely frustrated
and wednesday the prime minister
promised it will happen it's a slap in
the face
to see people putting themselves
putting their fellow citizens
putting
airline workers
at risk
by being completely irresponsible
the trips organizer is james william
awad originally in tweets that have now
been deleted he said the trip was a
success he's now saying he takes the
matter very seriously and is rethinking
what happened well they're also having
to rethink how to get home both air
canada and air transat say they won't
fly members of the group back to canada
the other concern for the influencers on
the flight is the damage to their
reputations self-inflicted the worst is
that it's actually those people who
actually put those images themselves on
social media
there is also another problem potential
penalties for their behavior transport
canada can fine people up to five
thousand dollars for each offense
mike armstrong global news montreal
fully vaccinated travelers to england
will no longer have to have a negative
pcr test before arriving and won't have
to self-isolate when they get there
prime minister boris johnson says the
measure came at a significant cost to
the travel industry and says it's having
little impact on the growth in cases
from 4am on friday we will be scrapping
the pre-departure test which discourages
many from traveling for fear of being
trapped overseas and incurring
significant extra expense we will also
be lifting the requirement to
self-isolate on arrival until receipt of
a negative pcr
incoming travelers will have to take a
rapid test no later than two days after
they arrive johnson says he's confident
britain can get through this latest wave
without imposing any further measures
even though daily case counts there are
breaking records and hospitalizations
are now doubling every nine days
the french president has taken a shot at
the unvaccinated saying he wants to put
in place policies that will piss them
off in a newspaper interview emmanuel
macron used what's considered a vulgar
term to describe how he wants to
pressure the unvaccinated to get the
shot his comments dominated headlines as
lawmakers debate a new vaccine passport
for months france has asked people to
show either proof of vaccination or a
negative covid test to access many
public venues macron wants to remove the
option to show a negative test a similar
approach other countries including
canada have taken
over 20 000 people are hospitalized with
cobit 19 in france
the appearance of tennis superstar novak
djokovic at this month's australian open
is in limbo the world number one ranked
men's tennis player landed in melbourne
today but there was a mistake with his
visa application australia has since
cancelled his visa and says he'll be
deported djokovic is expected to ca
challenge that decision he had received
a medical exemption to play in the
tennis tournament but he also needed to
make strict border rules to enter
australia djokovic has not said publicly
if he is vaccinated
a deadly tragedy in philadelphia coming
up the devastating fire that tore
through a home
[Music]
in philadelphia a fire has ripped
through a public housing building at
least 13 people have been killed
including seven children the fire chief
fears the death toll might rise as they
search the debris firefighters say there
were at least four smoke detectors in
the building but none of them went off
this is uh without a doubt one of the
most tragic days in our city
history um
loss of so many people in such a tragic
way losing so many kids
is just
devastating
neighbors say they awoke to screams and
flames 26 people lived in the two-unit
row house
well tomorrow marks exactly one year
since the u.s capitol in washington d.c
was stormed by supporters of donald
trump an attempted insurrection intended
to deny joe biden the presidency the
criminal investigation into who
orchestrated the siege is the largest in
fbi history and today the u.s attorney
general vowed to bring all the
perpetrators not just the ones directly
involved in the violence that day to
justice promising to follow the facts
wherever they lead
jackson proskow reports
one year later the investigation into
january 6th is growing deeper more than
700 rioters have been arrested
350 more are still wanted by the fbi
including the person who planted two
bombs that day the justice department
remains committed to holding all january
6 perpetrators
at any level
accountable under law
whether they were present that day
or were otherwise criminally responsible
for the assault on our democracy the
criminal investigation is paralleled by
a political one that seeks to understand
the role played by former president
donald trump
during a thursday speech from the
capitol president biden is expected to
address the actions of his predecessor i
would expect that president biden will
lay out the significance of what
happened at the capitol and the singular
responsibility president trump has for
the chaos and carnage that we saw the
january 6th committee has hinted it
believes trump had direct knowledge of
plans to interrupt certification of
biden's victory and is now requesting an
interview with fox news host sean
hannity on december 31st 2020 hannity
texted white house chief of staff mark
meadows i do not see january 6 happening
the way he is being told on january 5th
he texted an unknown recipient i'm very
worried about the next 48 hours what
could have been done to better secure
the capitol trump's allies continue to
deflect pointing the blame at capitol
police who were overwhelmed by the mob
the new chief of police told a hearing
his department is better prepared today
we will be tested again senator i mean
and i don't know who it's going to be or
when it's going to be one year after he
urged his supporters to march on the
capitol former president trump is
expected to stay entirely out of view he
canceled a planned press conference
where he was expected to perpetuate the
lie about a stolen election many
republicans worried about the message
that would send on a day meant to
commemorate the deadly attack on
american democracy
donna
all right jackson in washington thanks
turmoil in kazakhstan what's fueling the
fierce public anger
[Music]
kazakhstan is not a country we report on
very often but there is upheaval going
on there that the world is watching
there are violent public protests
prompted by a sudden rise in fuel prices
a state of emergency has been declared
nationwide
for some context kazakhstan is a former
soviet republic and is geographically
huge about the size of western europe it
sits between russia and china and has a
population of about 19 million it's not
a democracy and had the same president
nor sultan nazarbayev for almost 30
years until he unexpectedly retired in
2019. the country's current president
has since reduced fuel prices dismissed
the government and removed nazarbayev
from an important national security role
but as redmond shannon explains it's
unclear if that will restore calm
this is kazakhstan in chaos violent
protests fueled by anger over the price
of gas
at the start of the month liquid
petroleum costs doubled after the
removal of a price cap the fuel is used
by many poorer kazaks to power their
cars
but the demonstrations continued even
after the cap was restored government
buildings were set on fire wednesday and
some security force personnel were
reportedly killed as yet there is no
sign of a large police crackdown but the
internet has been cut off during the
country's state of emergency so much is
uncertain
president kassium jomar tokyo says
financially motivated conspirators are
behind the violence
he's the hand-picked successor of
long-time authoritarian leader nur
sultan
much of the anger this week is directed
at the former dictator superficially
he's revered the capital was renamed in
his honor in 2019 and he remained in a
key role as chair of the country's
national security council tokayev took
over the job wednesday in another
attempt to appease protesters experts
say it's unlikely to be enough you have
this country which is the size of
western europe but it the political
economy is only owned and controlled by
120 of these kind of elite families
analyst kate malenson says she's seen a
growing sense of injustice in kazakhstan
in recent years because the kazakh
government have decimated effectively
the systemic opposition in kazakhstan
there is now this kind of uncontrollable
spontaneous sort of massive protest
peacekeeping forces from former soviet
republics will now deploy to kazakhstan
to stabilize the situation russia keen
to see the status quo remain for a close
ally with huge mineral reserves some
russian media outlets are already
suggesting the crisis was stoked by
western powers something the white house
has denied redmond shannon global news
london
next have you chosen pets instead of
children the pope has some advice for
you
dogs have a whole lot of skills but not
every dog will save your life a thankful
hiker in croatia discovered his wood
eight-month-old north was hiking in the
mountains last week when his owner fell
and was unable to move fellow hikers
left to get help and north and alaska
and malamute curled up on the injured
man keeping him
warm for 13 hours when rescuers arrived
they said it proves friendship between
man and dog has no boundaries
pope francis had a different message
today in his audience at the vatican he
said those who choose pets instead of
children show a degree of selfishness
and that choice diminishes humanity the
decision to have kids of course is a
complex topic and as eric sorenson
reports the pope's comments have really
struck a chord
there are adults with young children and
there are adults with pets and no
children their lives are very different
for many reasons but pope francis has
compared them suggesting some
non-parents are being quote selfish
giving up on
being a mother or father
can take some of our humanity away from
us the pontiff suggested some couples
have pets instead of children but they
might have
two domestic animals two dogs or cats i
think that's incredibly cruel and unfair
tanya hails organization focuses on
parenthood she says people have pets to
love but not instead of children for
whom there are often bigger economic and
other factors there's so many reasons
that maybe someone does not want to
bring a tiny human being into the world
more adults are living without children
among canadian households one person
homes and couples without children now
represent more than half 54 percent
outpacing households with kids
statistics canada found the growth rate
for couples without children was up 7.2
percent over five years while couples
with children grew at just 2.3 percent
and it's true we are increasingly in
love with our pets canada's dog
population grew to 7.7 million in 2020
and there are even more cats 8.1 million
but are the numbers of children and pets
connected as the pope seems to suggest
he's implied that it's because of pet
ownership that
parenthood rates are falling and i'm not
persuaded that the first cause is the
second sociologist susan prentice
suggests many parents now make informed
decisions about parenthood rather than
the church making it for them it's a
good thing when folks get to control
their own fertility and make their own
choices the phenomenon of family policy
and falling birth rates goes a lot
further to explaining why fewer babies
are being born than does pet ownership
the pope also emphasized the importance
of adoption and on that tanya hales
agrees there are tons of babies being
born every day and whether there are
family pets or not there are children in
the world waiting for a family to take
care of them
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is peggy's cove lighthouse
in nova scotia beautiful spot we'd love
to see your canada please email your
photo to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Applause]
[Music]